- I was thinking about why
I was so fortunate
to have a, such a great
life and be so happy
and what was making that happen.
And I came to a conclusion
that it comes
down to the B-P-P
which is my Big Picture Patch.
Listen, I've got a
lot of stresses
and a lot of things
going on in my life
like anybody else.
We all have headaches and
there's so many things
going on in the world and
so many things to worry about.
And I think a lot
of its genetics and,
obviously, probably at
the end of the day
the biggest factor in my
overall happiness in life has
to come down to my parents.
What that means is that
no matter what's going on
you always have to
look at the big picture.
And the big picture is
the health and happiness
of the closest five to ten
people in your life.
And I have that and no
matter being on television
or being really sad,
when I think about that
that's all I really care about.
And by only caring
about the big picture
it helps me live my life.
(light music)